(typewriter keys clacking rhythmically)
(bell dings)
- My name is Alex Holman, and
I play tenor Smith Corona
with the Boston Typewriter Orchestra.
The Boston Typewriter Orchestra
is an ensemble for typewriter and voice.
Some of us have musical
backgrounds, some of us don't.
Several of our members
play in bands currently.
I haven't touched much of
anything, except for a typewriter,
since playing the trombone in high school.
We play a wide variety of typewriters,
from some small, portable models
all the way up to some
relatively large desk models.
A lot of what we do in building
up songs is really exploring
what different sounds we can
get out of the typewriter
and how we can incorporate
them into a song.
For example you have the key
makes it a basic clack sound,
um, but then you have the Shift
that moves a lot of the mechanics
and makes somewhat of a bass sound.
Then you also have the roller
that gets a (roller clicks),
gets sort of a mechanical,
ratchet sound to it.
Um, and then ultimately, we can work
with the carriage return for
(return rattles)
like the standard swoopy sound to it.
As our name suggests, the
Boston Typewriter Orchestra
is Boston-based, but
we've actually played
all over New England.
Most of the typewriters
are 50, 60, 70 years old.
Usually in our hands we see
two to three years of lifespan.
We beat on them pretty hard.
(audience applauding and cheering)
- My fingers hurt.
- When we started out in 2004,
we were a bunch of guys getting together
and kind of banging on typewriters.
We get that we're kinda weird.
It's a little bit of a wacky idea,
but we've discovered that this
makes some legitimate music
and it can be a real serious endeavor.
We have true songs that come together
and people seem to really enjoy them.
And as long as we still
are entertaining people
we're gonna stay out there, typing.
(audience applauding and cheering)
(electronic music)